[Music]
I'm Edie cook I'm the CEO and co-founder
of memorize memorize is a language
learning app and it combines a bunch of
interesting techniques for learning into
a very gamified experience so it
basically makes learning a language
joyful and entertaining today we are
here at Google for our design sprint
with memorize we're going to focus on
exploring a hands-free eyes-free
heads-up experience for their language
learning app a Google design sprint is a
tool for answering a critical business
question through design prototyping and
testing with users the benefit here is
time-saving you don't have to go down
the path spend six weeks two months of
development time on something that isn't
going to be valuable it also increases
the viability of the concepts because
you're bringing together
cross-functional teams I think a dream
result would be if we invented a new
learning mode which could really take
our learners away from the screen and
give us also new ideas for how to get
people listening to foreign language and
spending more time in the app the first
day we start by building shared
knowledge and we brainstorm we do how
might we post-it sharing an affinity
mapping and solution sketch that really
articulates some great ideas for the new
experience we are using our imagination
for something that doesn't exist yet and
trying to find a solution to that and
obviously a product feature that you
develop how can we imagine the users
like music memories most of them use
them in bed so it could be like a
lullaby and over the course of the day
we collected like hundreds of these how
might leads which are kind of pop
questions part ideas for features we
were able to categorize them and look at
the different areas of the experience
which we're going to want to design
around we try to generate eight ideas in
eight minutes and this time pressure
really helps people to get beyond their
first idea and push themselves towards
more innovative and interesting concepts
it was quite astonishing how many ideas
people have produced in fact one member
of the team Matilda has a list of ideas
so long that they would take a group of
500 skilled engineers a decade to
implement them all day - starts with a
presentation and review of the solution
sketch we follow that with a discussion
about assumptions and spirit questions
what we want to have answered in the
validation phase so for instance we had
lots of questions around the interaction
design around how we make the experience
as charming and fun as the in-app
experience is in memorize so that maybe
here in the tube it doesn't sound so
weird because it feels like you're
talking public hold on for a sec there
might be a cooking mode for example and
you say so help me cook Italian and then
once we've listed out what the
prioritized questions are that we have
we will do a voting session we ask them
to select the features or the pieces of
the concept that they're really
interested in trying out and testing
that's usually followed by a discussion
of what will be included in the
prototype and a storyboard for the user
testing for this team we are doing voice
control which is really exciting like
enjoy this one and then on the chat icon
these about on day three the prototyping
gets wrapped up the user interview
scripts get written and we prepare to
put these prototypes in front of the
users
pesco and this is really the part of the
sprint where we see the most value for
teams because they are really able to
get answers and validation to their
sprint questions that they're working
with we record and capture all of the
content from the user interviews and
they're often quite useful later on for
helping to articulate why design
decisions are made or white' development
decisions are made there's so much
goodness that came out of this design
sprint I also learned that one of the
ideas is very much something that we
could turn into a product feature almost
immediately I mean it was an amazing
experience for everyone I'm more
excitingly
I think we've learned enough about the
hands-free mode to see what it can't do
and what it can do just really can't
wait to see the impact of this adventure
you know not only on our ideas but also
on our communication and it's the
general kind of energy of the team it's
rather like meister eckhart supposed to
spirituality where most kind of
spiritual gurus talk about a long
winding painful path the top of the
mountain he had this approach was busy
to stick your head down and to run as
fast as you could and try and reach
spiritual enlightenment the fast way I
think is similar with a Google design
sprint is you just just kind of go for
it
[Music]